when you think of grilling most people
tend to lean more towards hardier meats
like beef and pork however fish is a
delish protein to add to your summer
recipe roster buckle up for the ultimate
guide to grilling fish
there are a lot of fish in the sea and
rivers and lakes but not all of them are
suited for grilling some fish can be a
bit too delicate fall apart and stick to
the grill but if you pick the right kind
it's actually easier than you think some
of our favorites are salmon and
swordfish other great options are whole
fish like trout red snapper or brenzino
let's talk about skin baby let's talk
about you and me okay sorry i'm ready
skin offer on is totally your personal
preference it won't change the outcome
of the fish a lot of people actually
really love eating the skin myself
included and when done right it can be
crispy and delicious obviously if you're
growing the whole fish route you need to
keep the skin on the skin protects the
flesh of the fish from being torn apart
by the grill here are three different
methods for cooking and preparing fish
first up we're going to grill marinated
swordfish over lemon slices
we're going with swordfish because it's
a super sustainable flavorful fillet
that holds up against the grill it's
almost like the steak of the sea
you can play around with endless flavor
combinations to create your ideal
marinade we're doing an easy herb to
citrus marinade you'll need olive oil
lemon juice lemon zest oregano salt and
pepper
just add everything together in a large
baking dish and whisk to combine
next add your fish for 30 minutes to an
hour
you don't want to go longer than that or
the acid from the lemon will start to
break down the fish and it'll get mushy
let's talk citrus
today we're using lemon slices but you
could also use limes oranges or even
grapefruit depending on what flavor
profile you're going for
make sure to cut your lemon slices into
fairly thick pieces so that they don't
disintegrate over the grill
when you're ready to start preheat your
grill to 350. place the lemon slices
side by side making sure it's bigger
than the filet of fish you're using
then place the fish on top of the lemon
slices and close the grill for 8 minutes
best part you don't even need to flip it
it'll go from being pink and kind of
translucent to being firm and opaque
just like this
if you're new to grilling fish this is a
great way to impart flavor while
preventing your fish from sticking to
the grill
and don't waste those grilled lemons
they're perfect for squeezing over fish
for even more brightness and flavor
for our next method we're doing
something a little more unique and using
a cedar plank a cedar plank is a great
way to impart a smoky flavor into the
fish again without dealing with the
possibility of the fish sticking to the
grill we're really trying to make it
easy on you guys and ourselves cedar
planks and salmon are a classic combo
that go hand in hand the fat from the
salmon is great for absorbing the flavor
of the wood in the summer most grocery
stores carry cedar planks in the seafood
section but you can also find them
online take your seed of planks and
submerge them in water for at least an
hour before grilling you could even do
this the day before
soaking the wood is going to prevent it
from catching fire on the grill
pretty crucial
before we get grilling let's talk rubs
you can really go anywhere with your
spice combinations for our rub we're
going to use whole grain mustard brown
sugar orange zest salt pepper
coriander and cumin
combine all the ingredients in a bowl
and just whisk until smooth
it's as easy as that
if you choose to keep the skin on like
we're doing you only need to worry about
covering the top and the sides with the
rub
generously cover the salmon with the rub
it's totally okay if it's a little
uneven as long as it's covered this
doesn't need to marinate you can get
right to grilling
when you're ready to go
place the soaked cedar planks over
indirect heat and place the salmon on
top
close the lid and cook for 15 to 17
minutes
the beauty of cedar planks means no
flipping or sticking
when you're done the salmon should be
pink in the center and easily flake
apart and the mustard rub should turn
into this kind of crust on top it's so
good
when you take a bite of the cedar plank
salmon it'll be hard to go back this is
a whole new level of flavor that's so
easy to achieve
our final method is stuffing and
grilling a whole fish
okay this is going to seem intimidating
but it's actually one of the easiest and
most forgiving methods it's guaranteed
to be a centerpiece showstopper
when buying a whole fish make sure to
ask your fishmonger to clean and get the
fish
it's not super fun to do yourself but by
all means be my guest
you're probably thinking what about the
bones don't worry we'll remove them
later
you can essentially stuff the cavity
with anything you'd like we're seasoning
our fish with salt and pepper next stuff
it with lemon slices scallions ginger
and cilantro then finish it off by
coating it with oil on both sides
we're seasoning the fish from inside out
so it's really crucial that you season
every bit of it with salt and pepper
the measurements for the stuffing don't
need to be exact take a handful of each
and stuff them gently inside the cavity
once your fish is full of flavor it's
time to tie it up things are about to
get wild take two pieces of cooking
twine per trout and slip them under the
body tying it around the belly of the
fish and making a bow or not on top sure
you could do some fancy chef tie
but it's really not necessary make your
life easier and just do a bow
the most important thing here is that
the fillings stay inside
lastly generously coat each fish with
olive oil on both sides
again with this method you can skip
marinating and get right to grilling
this time take a paper towel and dip it
into a bowl of oil and thoroughly rub
down the grates of the grill
this in tandem with the oil on the fish
is going to make sure there's limited
sticking if any place the fish over
indirect heat
and close the grill for six minutes
now it's time for the hardest part
when it's time to flip take a deep
breath
if it sticks just take your tongs and
gently wiggle the fish until it releases
from the grill
once you've successfully flipped your
fish close the grill and continue
cooking for another six minutes
a whole fish is all about presentation
before you present it cut and remove
each piece of twine
remember how i told you we're going to
take out the bones now's the time
on a cutting board or hey even on your
plate
remove all the stuffings from the fish
and gently split the fish open you'll
notice the bones begin to separate from
the meat run your fingers under the
bones and along the spine then take the
tail and pull it straight up this will
remove the bones and head in one fell
swoop
it's really that easy
the secret to grilling great fish is
finding a method to prevent sticking
without overcooking it it doesn't need
to be scary or messy you can play around
with different flavor combinations and
are proven grilling techniques to get
the perfect fish
every time so there you have it whatever
method you choose i hope you expand your
fishy horizons and give one of these a
try
and it's so good
there's no reason not to do it go fish
or go home bam
i'm out